hello everybody hi there
happy Friday yes times weird for me
because I've been gone yes for the week
everybody happy Friday sorry for the
late delay we were having some weird
issues with some PC steam stuff but
we're all set I'm not Ben chenkin I'm
John it's a whole thing but we're here
Monster Hunter is back it's on PCs on PC
ice-born is finally on PC every week
some community Fridays which also means
it's Monster Hunter Fridays for us and
we're gonna we're gonna with with you
lovely yeah folks so there's the sound
so we're gonna hop in here yeah I'll
make the thing and I'll put it under our
pit you guys yeah I haven't got a chance
to really jump into the PC version
because I actually just got my PC
account caught up to be able to do
ice-born oh nice I replayed it last year
on PC with my brother I was like really
excited and then they were like hey I
support it's gonna be later and I was
like come on because I was radius which
permanently PC now now it's there and I
can finally switch over to PC properly
slicker we're in it okay for me let's do
it it's been a while okay cool am I in
the Destructoid group for oh it does
like um so take your seat it takes your
steam whatever default steam group so
mines like giant bomb from like years
ago because I guess I think giant bombs
like my default steam group still that's
wild we have a GameSpot group we should
probably probably switch it to that yeah
we should probably should okay I have it
made give me a sec people okay you can
see it up here to stuff you wanna join
hot seconds while I attempt to
transition been filled for time alright
uh so how many people have actually are
like us and made the switch that's what
I'm curious about
cuz after moving from like my 500 hour
plus game save on the PlayStation 4 I
actually feel kind of good about being
on PC like the frame rate increase and
it's really nice just yeah everything's
really really nice from it I wanna also
I kind of feel bad that I abandoned my
original character and also I only have
that that gift armor that they gave
everyone to kind of boost them through
the original game feel kind of guilty
about that it's alright though make sure
we run around and talk to everyone ok
I'm almost there
it's all good I've almost got it
got the Steamworks back here oh there
it's a provisional okay so I think the
next thing I might have to fight is the
we'll see in a second thing about
switching us have 100 or 1k hours and
ps4 yeah it's I wish there was like they
did a destiny thing where you'd like
sync your accounts across or something
that would be a lot of when they do a
monster in world 2
that's gotta be it's got to have cross
play it's at least cross save at least
cross save hopefully cross play and with
that that means everything should
hopefully also will be simultaneous
release okay there we go everybody
that is our code we've done it we've
done it everything's okay alright yeah
it's just been playing normally me and
Ben would both be playing but because of
the way this room set up it's not really
well set up for multiple pcs at the
moment so for now it's just gonna be
been today but that means more of you
can play with us at the same time it's a
huge sort thing yeah Monster Hunter is
real big up into their their giant
weapon what are you rocking the switch
axe okay yeah so I was trying to get
back into longsword and then I decided
against it I did a do charge blade on PC
charge Boyd's really fun but I'm still
not like good enough with it but I want
to do it doubles as a cello
it's a they're like ice board and stuff
for charge but I just added more things
you can charge and I'm like okay there's
even more cuz it's like a rhythm of like
you this this this and activate that
then do that and then hit that so now
they just added more things you gotta
eight yeah the new moves are still
really cool and I was mr. oneth the bug
lamps for the first time since iceborn
mm-hmm and they added a whole bunch more
stuff to kind of control how you buff
your weapon which was really nice I love
this music this is a good game it's very
good there's a really good expansion to
we would have I think you and me would
have really dived into it way more if it
wasn't for the fact that it came out
during an incredibly busy time of the
year yeah for us at the GameSpot office
cuz we have to cover a lot of games
Jennifer barber because I remember when
world first released it came out around
this time in January where nothing was
happening it was like a really dive into
it maybe I'll get back into this a
little bit mom PC yeah and the other
part too like I dropped like reminder
that you can join our session ID yeah
yeah if you have ice-born you want to
play with us I should drink one of these
hot drinks but even though I was I was
doing that I was kind of like I want to
make the jump to the PC so I don't know
if I want to like go too hard in it so
now I'm able to feel like this is kinda
like my chance to like finally like dig
in dig in i apologies people i'm like
adjusting the
I mean you believe there are people out
there who don't like the handler what
yeah that's crazy oh no you can't see
the ID in the snow hold on help fix that
give him sweet I'm so more of like a
guilt marm guy but the handle was really
cool I can't even see it it's like white
hold on that's why I help at all it's
okay I'll sit in it get those
achievements here we go and there's
useless yeah but she's the handler she's
a dog I think she's adorable yeah like I
said so not as good as the guild marm
I'm calling me doodle all the time but
he was good make sure you so I'm not
gonna eat just cuz it's the discovery
quest so I'm gonna back out as soon as
we find him don't worry about it then
but this is probably one of my favorite
designs from this expansion though I
really love this dumb like moose t-rex
so much here we go sorry I keep messing
with the text I'm just trying to
we'll monster hunting things oh you know
that would be the good way to do it
recommend my honor I agree with Derrick
I wholeheartedly recommend Monster
Hunter it's got one heck of a learning
curve because once you get over that
beats
it's some of the best times
there we go lie down now that we've
discovered
I'm solo
oh yeah sure
a lot of funny though yeah all right
this is game okay to solo or not did you
answer that one or not yes answer is yes
absolutely easy it's pretty easy to sell
oh and it's like totally viable play
with people if you can and there's some
of the like the really hard challenges
like the late-game stuff that you want
other people for but just getting
through the the game of the campaign and
and experiencing every monster totally
solo it I actually played during the the
preview time most of it was so load mhm
just because it was only like us in the
office that's entirely solo bull dude I
love the gathering him on this one it's
it's got everything and people joined in
yet so I'm gonna see see if we can take
some people to fight this this angry
t-rex moose if not oh wow is the picture
there that's that's a lot yep it how
dare you been I'm just
it's a real real old throwback um
alright so don't have anyone in here yet
so I can just go and it's open right
like they didn't join okay as long as
you use the numbers a reminder that you
can join our session ID if you're
playing hope people are playing and I
was like day one but yeah so get some
food so you're gonna hop in and they
made people on mid that's good way to it
yeah you can join mid-match mid Hunter
Seban what are for those who are
watching right now who don't know this
is like our we try and make it weekly
live show it's a new year I feel like
it's new a new shot
a new chance we want it we want to give
it our best chance we want to try and
keep coming Friday is going on the
regular camera for a second I want to
check something just thinking about
stuff yeah want to make sure okay that's
that's close that's good all right okay
cool cool cool so I make sure that like
things didn't didn't pop up yeah but we
are we're gonna try and do it more on
the regular we are gonna be trying to
find cool games we want to do it with
sounds like we got a couple of fun
opportunities comes out for doomed I do
miss the one I'm really looking forward
to because the games got that
multiplayer mode but it also has a
invasion mode in the campaign where
people can like invade your game while
you're playing and if that is set to a
way where you can like put like a code
in or something where we could tell
people like hey invade us while we're
playing I think that would be super cool
that's that's the type of thing but
other games that we can play that would
be fun to play with you guys are please
blue not please blue sorry gran blue
yeah gran blue fantasy that comes out a
couple weeks we like playing fighting
games here that's our big thing
[Music]
y'all stocked up ready to go to make
sure everything's all such a cool drink
your hot drink or I already drank it
your grab these hot peppers just cuz
this expansion is gonna be hard it it's
definitely uh a tougher challenge it's a
bass game I don't think it's a it
doesn't feel impossible not unmanageable
now but it is tougher for sure
Brennan mentions out Joker coming out MK
11
I should probably brush up on Mortal
Kombat so feel like even though it's
only been like like two weeks I feel
like it's been forever since I've like I
don't like you've done anything I think
the thing I'm looking forward to is we
are so this will probably be the last
community Friday's we do in this room
which is like regular stream room and
we're gonna be trying to switch it over
and doing it in our main studio upgrades
upgrade to our main studio and the big
advantage of that is that we have space
for more people yeah I want to do a lot
more getting other people on so you and
me so even if we play games that we're
not maybe the best at you and me as
hosts and we could get we get people in
there who are experts yeah so we said
someone like max for Dragon Ball or so
that's exciting he did all of our combo
videos he did do all of our combo videos
I mean that dude is uh he's good yeah
he's good at games
during the debate Otis so I'm supposed
to be fighting the the borrow the ban
barrels okay trying to find his
footsteps and I'm going in the wrong
territory
usually he's in the back over there and
he could just find him right away but it
doesn't seem like that's the case he's
here area is my boy
who's that grapple is that crap all the
way to finish me that's pretty good to
slow em do their thing
no no you ran away ran away he's a
grapple grab on if I do he's gonna he's
gonna yell and knock me off right away
so I'm gonna get him to yell
I don't have all my gear from the ps4
yet this guy is just so cool no no yeah
do it ah this is like my favorite things
be put in this hole oh yeah it's so good
is just it completely changes the way
you use just you do everything get back
up
nice nice
dang dude very upset getting them big
hits in yeah it's that it's the switch
actually just kind of ride it out there
for a bit I did the the new attack that
the I did the expansion to app for us
which acts which forget the exact
where's um Dragon's Dogma - asks zero
that's a good question I know that it's
to know who he directed Dragon's Dogma
one right I believe would be like we're
like pretty estate or something it was a
lot of there's a lot of Monster Hunter
involvement but it's you know the guy
made who work sometimes when I cry who I
believe also worked on Dragon's Dogma Qi
who said that he's very interested in in
doing a follow up to it that doesn't
necessarily mean it's happening just
that he has expressed personal interest
in wanting to to do another one so I
hope so I've never actually played
Dragon's Dogma but I've heard very good
things it's it seems like something
that'd be right up my alley it's a
really cool super open-ended like RPG
with Monster Hunter gameplay which is
kind of like the best thing yeah I mean
that sounds great
and I thought weird climbing mechanic
you're like climbing all over the dudes
and it looked really funny and awesome
it's you got it got it I'm just I'm
doing the dance
get back to that tail there we go
oh dude that is it's so good so
satisfying to watch poor guy got right
in the way no dude that's the biggest
bummer with the charge blade we get
these uh you you feel because charge
blade you're like building up your your
uh your meter and you're like okay it's
powerful powerful this one strike is
gonna do like a huge amount of damage
and then you miss yeah because they move
at the last second or something you're
like that is a real risk/reward type
weapon when it's really really sad it's
super satisfying when you pull it off
brennon horrendous says glad GameSpot
after darkus on YouTube now yes yeah
yeah for those who don't know GameSpot
after darkest hour podcast that we do
and we've been doing it for a little
less than half a year now
we thought that we started back in like
August and we finally have a video
version of it so that will also be up
every week on YouTube for all of you who
prefer a video version but for those of
you who have listened to the audio
version and just prefer the audio
version that will stay the exact same no
real changes to that the video version
is video but it's not it's not video
focused in a way where it would feel
like you're missing out on something
yeah by having the audio version unless
is like a direct call out for me like
being an idiot and doing something with
my hands sure I mean we kind of do that
anyway on the audio version you just
just grab it more but yeah it's not like
we're gonna have like videos playing or
anything that you're not going to be
able to understand
so we got that really cool interaction
just now with the two of them fighting
about turf wars going on
I got monster and roll dice born but on
ps4 bummer yeah we wanted to see if
anyone on PC was playing hop on they
gotta at that cross play man on Tanya
they really do it's got to be a big
thing for the next generation I feel so
- that is my big prediction is that a
huge focus for the next generation is
gonna be at the very least cross save
yeah and then cross play for everything
that that makes sense I would really
really love that yeah can you do cross
aims no unfortunately you cannot Derek
O'Neill points out that dauntless is
cross play and saving it's amazing yeah
true that's that's an excellent example
of a a game that does both and like
again I just think that needs to be the
standard for every game going forward in
the next generation which I feel very
strongly will happen
Oh
nice oh there's a bad time to do that
when he's coming back up though that's a
different situation to the wall
what's gonna finish that and I was like
it's all good I might I might get what
is I might get called into a room a per
oh the Avalanche oh no I forgot about
this
ah dude I barely got this when I play on
ps4 I love when [ __ ] like this happens
ah now don't do it
oh those iframes on that that dive dodge
ah dude you're getting cold you need a
hot drink okay
don't worry though we're good you're
good because that vigor waft revival
it's real clutch that's also an addition
they added that I super appreciate hey
guys alright we're good we're good
everything's back on track
pick that up it's very important
just pop monster I scrolled ice-born for
PC heck yeah man and say there's a big
sale master was only like 15 or 20 bucks
oh nice
that's pretty good
yeah I think if you buy that the nice
thing is you you if you never played
monster underworld and you buy it now it
comes to both yeah so it's a really good
way to you're getting a good deal you're
getting a lot of content who this game
cap comes biggest seller now ah yes it
still I think so there are a couple
games that yeah they've been doing
really well lately but I remember this
was like a huge this sold really really
well for them which is why I'm like
they're all 100% via a world - yeah I'm
just stoked that we don't have to worry
about keeping Master Hunter only on
portable platforms feel like they've
made a pretty good case for it to be on
modern systems about proper consoles
didn't resident evil 3 drop yet no
resonable threes in March but you know
where we're gonna be stoked about that
yeah I'm very excited for resident evil
3 big scene row 0 3 is I have an equally
spicy take which is resin evil 3 is one
of my least favorite Resident Evil games
we go but that's actually why I'm really
excited for the remake because I mean my
issues was resin evil for me were the
very specific it's a shot at redemption
so it's like I the the overall concept
of resin evil 3 is fine so the idea of
them improving on that is exciting they
could they could make it make me fall in
love with the remake
it's not hurting too bad yes we're
making progress
big shame on you for not like your isn't
evil 3 that's fair I get a lot of heat
when I say I don't like it
too far I get all I heat for saying it's
one of my favorites
it just has some real clunky movement to
it like it see it they they try to make
that games faster paced and more action
II you can dog that with the system that
shove that doesn't feel feels tacked on
and it just doesn't it doesn't feel
right to me
and then that games also got a couple of
real real poor moments where you can get
locked it locked in and you have to do a
fight with nothing
yeah be a little be a little rough you
guys should do halo community Friday's
of GameSpot office and stream its we
definitely want to do halo yeah again is
I'm PC we've got a slow streamer
releases for Halo on PC now yeah very
exciting
don't fall over this time my dude take
it easy
try to get his tail come on
oh hello what oh no it's okay it's been
doing this since yesterday holy a second
it comes back I don't know why is that
an issue with your the game or your PC
here it's the first time I've ever seen
the game do it and I don't think it's
but your PC was doing it so it's not
with your PC maybe it might be something
with like ice-born Hawkeyes to be honest
I don't know idea that was yes that was
terrifying I only was comfortable with
it because I'd seen it they try to pull
down oh Christ to you before Donnell
crisis T was that what you mean
either way love that game love Jill
there I actually died no crisis I'd like
to see it redone too I like the idea of
Dino crisis but you know someone at
Capcom was like flip and Reggie will to
remake this so well what about the like
everyone else in the meeting rooms like
well obviously we should do three necks
and then the one guy in the corner put
Donal crisis the title crisis and then
someone in the way way back who never
gets hurt is like the power stubble and
then the guy keeps saying Mega Man
Legends 3 they just they walked him into
profit long ago they they have they have
tied him up and put him in a closet
long ago Derek says that may have been a
memory leak
probably I will say I love Jill
Valentine
Jill's my favorite resin he will protect
Jill Valentine is is wonderful I vastly
prefer every time I play Resident Evil 1
I always pick Jill
I also liked it because she's the easier
option she's the easier option but
honestly it has more to do with Jill and
Barry is the Rica's like their I love
Jill I love Barry and all their dialogue
any chance is hilarious this is always
good they have all the best dialogue
especially in the original version
played chicken oh no that's right I'm
already dodging this is fine
y'all hating on Ashley all right
[Music]
just going back to running away
I try capturing
yeah that's it's a heck of a thing Myra
says hey this may be the wrong place ask
was anyone experiencing issues with the
game it wasn't since ice-born are your
issues the game is freezing up because
you might actually be in the right place
to ask same here maybe it is just a
thing with ice born then uh yeah you
guys are all having random freezes then
don't worry you're not alone
oh yeah that's right they don't they
don't fall asleep if you're too close to
a man yes that is a change yeah they did
maybe a martyr in that respect as she
from residue before yeah that's what
they were trying to it Ashley
oh my gosh the frenzy for let's just try
she's fine come on over here get him
come on come on buddy yeah
nice throw that drink see if this is
enough good job we're doing it uh my
ruse is they're not having random
freezes but a low FPS at time and my
best friends PC fully crashed oh that's
not good
mmm sounds like there might just be a
couple of technical issues with the PC
version yeah we got a rare pick up here
just in time
well hopefully they are not stuff soon
then yeah it's like I said it's not
caused me to outright crash or anything
yet which is good it is kind of
frustrating until I could be in the
middle of a fight and have it just be
like oh wait a second processing what's
going on Walter felt cheap to you
controls aren't that great my taste in
games varies just wasn't feeling that's
fair hey you know sometimes you just
don't feel like a feel of game yeah I
actually admittedly like the first time
I played Master Hunter thought the
controls were awful monster hunter does
have a learning curve to to the way it
behaves you have to you have to sort of
so accept the way it is and kind of get
used to that like fast supposed to be
like a double me cry but I'm fighting
monsters yeah it's much more slow and
deliberate than that yeah it's it's
definitely not for everybody so there's
no shame in being like it wasn't for me
but I'm glad that you gave it a go East
and tried it out
any good guesses when Capcom will patch
the issues um I assume that if there are
widespread issues they're already
working on whatever yeah
um are you saying worlds there first
Capcom game and I have no idea how fast
reliable they are Capcom when it comes
to patches they work on them pretty
quick and you know that they obviously
see it they see everyone having the
issues are talking about right a monster
we as we mentioned earlier monster
hunter world is a pretty big game for
them so that's not the kind of thing
they would want to let sit yeah broken
for very long so hopefully pretty soon
but I couldn't tell you like you know
the get fixed before we put out the
other need Chris Redfield is giving me
the walk through these accesses oh good
hua has cat grandma sound
she's the estera chefs former mentor
she's come out of retirement to help us
out she's adorable
scrape though you can't you can't pick
the vo to be not only like you pick like
Japanese if you want and that's fun but
you can pick the Monster Hunter language
yeah and their which describe how it
sounds it sounds sort of like Japanese
but not entirely it's like Japanese
Simlish kind of sounding I think that's
fun now you can still pick bad as an
option to go preview I spawn I actually
made a joke about Chris Redfield being
the person who takes you through
everything some reason actually took me
a little while to realize that was his
name was actor's name I forget Chris
Redfield he also did Batman in Batman
Arkham origins yep inez the current
voice of Sonic the Hedgehog yeah it's a
pretty big one how is his name chat help
me yeah the the velizar fight is wild
your first time through it is the the
Valhalla variant and this one is yeah
also very tough it's those are the
fights that are like they try to tell
like teach you like a hard thing about
yeah like all right time they find it
more people
I love this that there's no reason for
this to even be here but I love it so
much it's a fun little minigame yeah
it's got really good cutscenes those
guys are super stoked yeah they are
yeah ball huzzah can I spawn yeah what
we won't spoil too much but they do have
a couple of elder dragon variants and
ice-born some of the older ones and
they're fun so let's just let's do this
once for the heck of it do it
cool help the Steamworks yeah so there's
no as far as I know way to like actually
like do this it's it's only at there are
certain moments when the cats will
actually tell you what it is yeah but it
that's not like all the time the way
that I do it is all I'll do I'll do why
and sometimes it works Chris Redfield
asks I've never played it and if I buy
I'll probably play it solo do you
recommend it I highly recommend it it's
great you can totally play it solo I've
I played the game majority of it solo so
yeah if this looks interesting to you
and you want to try it you can play the
entire game solo you don't have to be
online even it is it is totally possible
to play this game by yourself and in
fact like yeah it's kind of little
easier in some ways because the monsters
actually scale properly for a different
size but yeah the monster scale properly
also this game does have a really
annoying thing where you can't watch
cutscenes in a party like yeah but you
have to watch the cutscene solo and then
you can join it so actually playing the
campaign solo is a little bit less of a
headache because of that which is I mean
that's kind of lame it's pretty lame
it's not kind of it is lame and I hope
that those fixes it I was really hoping
they fixed in nice born it might be like
two hardwired into the setup I don't
know because they have to know people
thought that sucked
yeah and for whatever reason they
couldn't fix it at least in an expansion
but hope it to does some really good
they were talking about Chris Redfield
and he's in the chicks yeah thanks Chris
Redfield appreciate you stopping by he's
also uh Ezio and this house was great
drew what's his name we should get like
currently Chris Redfield isn't he didn't
they didn't they get a different answer
for seven maybe
that's fine we we did and for doing all
this you just get like cool like items
and stuff that you need for your yeah
doing Roger Craig Smith that's that's
the actor it's you auditory yeah he's
done a bunch of stuff
yeah they got David Vaughn to do him in
a seven you know I'm actually there's
all the talk about three and people are
excited for that I really want to see
what Resident Evil 8 is I want to follow
up to 707 is weird I've seen a lot of
actually backlash towards seven lately
like um people bring it up people bring
up how like disappointing 7 was I
completely disagree I love 7 yeah I
think 7 is fantastic it's not perfect by
any means it definitely has things could
be improved on but I really really like
7 a whole whole lot craft more traps but
I don't have what I need so that's the
other downside of this is I had like all
of the the side quests completed for
unlocks so I could just like go over to
my my box and have it like cultivate the
stuff I need for traps but I need to
catch up on all that still right yeah
that's fine oh well on this expedition
yeah find this next thing we got a fight
reminder that if anyone's playing on PC
and they want to join us they you can
totally do that yeah seems like a lot of
people either are having issues or maybe
are just like getting through the basic
by themselves yeah
it's me so I got all my my dumb emotes
oh I'm like double me cry it oh nice
Derrick O'Neal on the chat with a hot
tips for new players catching mobsters
increases reward and researches done
faster yes true if you uh it's always
better to capture than it is to hunt
them and so it also is worth mentioning
I think you can only get certain
materials by like actually killing them
- yes so I would say very not very many
but what I would say is if you are that
is so good right if you are just trying
to fight the monster and not necessarily
looking for anything specific you should
try and capture it because you'll just
generally get more stuff it's only when
you are trying to get a very specific
material off of monster that you should
check your book and it'll tell you
whether you'll get it through hunting or
through capture and that's when you kind
of make that also tell you from the
research like what parts of the monster
you need to break to break the getting's
it's not it's not like a huge thing but
capturing is almost always the best
option it's also nicer you know you have
to do a doing like it's murder on
everything if you don't want to know I
really do like the snow effects
oh man thinking of snow bring back a
lost planet yeah I'd like to play a lost
planet but I want them to kind of go
back to what that game was before
well because Lost Planet one I remember
just being like a real cool game with
like fun snow physics and multiplayer
actually kind of cool so I I really
liked like 2 because 2 is just monster
house monster on her but with ayan
played teams in space but but - so
different from what one was so I didn't
like - at first that's fair when I
played it because two is just such a
different game from one and I'm like I
was like no I don't want this I wanted
to I wanted what one was I wanted more
one maybe if I go back to - now that
I've like gone in a monster hunter I'd
appreciate it more but I really didn't
care for - at the time I also really
like the like different setups and zones
- yeah like having the different
factions like the one out in the desert
and having to do that big train fight
like you just do a co-op run through a
Lost Planet - that'd be fun
can I get my my gears of war Marcos skin
yeah
or Frank West's that'd be pretty yeah
Nico Frank West with his giant backpack
I never played three I heard it was kind
of whatever I wait a little bit of it I
don't try to go back to sort of one and
it it almost like - kind of like a
horror game yeah at least like a trailer
did stay here my phone washing clearly
the the titles wrong is you're not
playing with me esteemed mm but uh if if
you do want to play games with us in the
future and you don't have like Monster
Hunter on the PC or anything like that
miss any of the shows that we do you
stream every weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific
yeah our shows on Fridays where we try
to play with you it's open it is open so
it's good to go with anyone but
we don't just play things on PC or just
on Xbox we play whatever we can try to
keep it kind of relevant but sometimes
we'll just play something cuz we want to
it's a good time though Derek is uh
Yulin I either collect a lot of frozen
bones yeah I should probably be
collecting them I should also be getting
these ores I should be doing a whole
bunch of things I'm I'm kind of
following along and looking at the chat
though mm-hmm I'm prioritizing talking
to you guys over gathering over playing
the game well which probably isn't the
best way to do it I also should have
done my hot drink but I'm gonna back out
of this as soon as it happens yeah I hit
that but it'll be fine everything will
be a-okay whoo yeah oh you're just doing
like though you walk around and then
they're gonna play a cup saying it yeah
yeah just oh man do you have no stamina
yeah what's I mean I could have done the
hot drink and all that but I'm just
gonna back out as soon as we find oh I
see what you're trying to do like I
could like build everything up for this
but it's just gonna be us going and
finding the next monster and right right
they both came in here at the same spot
but we ended up over here you're slowly
dying please help them you're also
wearing an outfit that is not good not
good you have like no sleeves and then
you got like your metal armor which
means it's just doubly cold it's a real
bad setup oh this boy
yeah the Viper Toby kodachi monster
designs in these games oh good good like
even though this is like a returning
variant of a monster it's just there's
so many little things that give you good
like visual cues as to what it does
valera Dom you get from this region is
amazing I love the armor that is that it
is really good a nice born and even the
the master variants for the older armors
are really good like they look great I
love the way they look so I'm a huge
definitely huge fan of all the all the
monster stuff the armor and stuff
they've added yeah it's it's a huge
compelling reason to keep buying this
game from tui do we have all the layered
armor stuff like do we know if all the
updates on the PC are the same ones that
are on yes yeah ok that's good yeah yeah
like I believe it like the only thing
that would not be the same between them
at this point is the event stuff
yeah like the certain event stuff like
the a LOI and that kind of thing
Ragnarok so what we do is you go and
start it up to trigger the cutscene and
then we head back that way we can like
properly party up so that other people
can join us if we want yeah it's just
all an elaborate setup yeah it's a
little it's a little confusing and but
yeah it's basically just our way of
doing it so that people can properly
join if they want what you can do with
this session ID right here it's we've
got that number set up right right for
you here on the steam platform it's
finally on PC but our gonna go fight
this boy yeah yeah what a pardon
drink it's good this is good take one of
those and we're off
I think he's probably still gonna be
down on the same spot
grab some of this on the way even I
don't really need it
Derek reminding us about and doing
paralyzed and poison at the same time
it's true I also don't have a lot of the
like covers and drive and that's a real
bummer but still think we can make it
work I think so I don't want to fight
you yeah I had done most of this stuff
on PC I think where I ended I just
hadn't done a couple like the real real
late stuff but I had done pretty much
everything on PC alright you were here
where did you go where'd you come from
where did you go
to fight VIPRE
Toby Kedah Qi lost track of the monster
seems a left area wants a different one
yeah it's gonna say that one wouldn't
leave just says mission failed
like what all right looks like we're on
the right track footprints look like
they're pointed the right way here we go
alright you should get the thing pretty
soon yeah
I do like the added more like proper
tracking in this one mm-hmm cuz before
just be like you've got to go and know
where the monsters show up and you got a
where I paintball it and sometimes you
could wave to like the hot air balloon
and it would point out where they are to
you
that's cuz I'm in combat isn't it yeah
sometimes it just like doesn't work
right we're a little you'll kind of lose
it for a second
yeah well finicky are you leading me
here again just kill those I know that
he's gonna show up in this area so I
should probably just head back there
anyway
there we go okay here we are now follow
that trail what are you doing okay can
you open up and tag him at this point
cuz I think we've we've now locked him
properly he's right up over there okay I
see him cool yeah we got him he's on his
way he's just taking this time crap on
him oh he's got meat Hey I've been able
to do it because there was a dual blades
and I can like hit it fast enough but I
was always able to do that I don't have
the you know what yeah it's because I'm
on dual blades you actually have a
specific move you can do with the
grapple when you grapple onto them so I
would always just crap on immediately
like do that like downward slash move
there we go nice I love doing the
mounting a lot and that might be like
an actual problem why cuz sometimes like
go out of my way to do it when I
shouldn't oh yeah this is like some sort
of weird invisible like bar for when you
can do it again I don't even know that
it's like like a stump meter in Street
Fighter I think is how it works because
if you do it too much it'll like it has
to be like reset or brought back
and that's always a problem I have in
games where especially a fighting game
I'm like I just really want to do this
one move on you even though it's like
dude that's not the ideal time to use
this move here like but I want to use it
I want to do my spinning bird kick
exactly and then you die because you're
just trying to you're just trying to
pull off something cool but like oh
ji-hun it's like I'm gonna actually
fight competently and the full core
engine Athas here now - I don't need
that he's tough I really like just how
he's like an electric version of himself
now and his mouth like just looks really
neat what if I brought him over here
what if I made them fight I should make
them fight hey come over here he did it
get upset of him oh so Derek's saying uh
you the little icon on them you know
where it is yellow and turns red when
it's yellow that means you can throw
them against the wall but if it's red if
it's red they're they're enraged it
means that you can't ya that's generally
how you tell like what like even though
this guy's not in a red state right now
I probably shouldn't
alright cuz they're fighting each other
I just want them there we go that's what
I want do that turf war yeah dude that's
so cool
right I need about to leave to you so
you're good now it's fine you go he got
a little bit of hit Sun on like a
Rooney's oh I'm on the wrong part of him
also I don't have enough energy to do
this Oh God you got him very nice pulled
it off oh no no one invited you over
here uh he like really knocked you out
cuz you were going ham yeah okay now
they haven't turbo we're gonna both hit
each other oh that's okay
Oh video game oh wow calm down game oh
that's not even what that's not who I
was fighting again he left and then now
they're fighting excuse me pardon me
get through here oh boy
what you doing down here hanging out
that's cool well I should take a nap
nice good call I don't have any Wow
I'm not equipped for any of this Oh Oh
at least uh yeah no sorry we'll just hit
him really hard can you charge up a
little bit or I can do like this is
always like a hard thing to get the
spacing down for but if I do this and
then try to like okay that work there
you go that's pretty good what's for
lunch today guys whatever
don't you dare I was like fighting them
in here because it's got like the little
edge that I can do that on yeah enjoys
that's me do like a cool check to see if
I can mount them again
oh no you're good you're good fights
going very well well I'm not worried
we're doing all right I actually thought
this would be more challenging than it
was I think you fought him before so you
know what to expect
that's how I felt when I like replayed
it on PC it was like oh no done always I
know what I'm doing
also this this catch-up here that they
give you it's really good it's really
good there it's very nice of them to do
that right through that paralysis cloud
there it is oh good hit
hot drink effects of worn off it's good
thing we're down on the ground now
yeah Oh thought he's gonna come forward
hey buddy doing you go for that jump
aren't you yeah I was
I'm always going for the job nice
the combo was so good I felt that that
tail
let's go around in a circle a whole
bunch I got this there we go good job
the camera resolution is all pixels
[Music]
shouldn't be we're looking fine on our
end
check out the stream preview movies hey
check out the stream preview Pixley I
can see I can see what you're saying I'm
not sure why though that's better now
okay maybe it was just a weird weird
Hitchin thing like fooling us now though
yeah
get this boy he's uh he's got to be
close
yeah hey pal she's doing in here oh yeah
oh no I think it's a you had that more
enclosed one for a little bit but I
don't think that's like you knock it
down that's more it does it on its own
what hunter rank are they do you know
what your hunter rank is oh it's very
low basically did like you just powered
through it to get to the to the DLC
right but I'm I'm ps4 am like yeah pcs
not Ben's main main character I think
I'm PC I'm I'm I'm actually only like
maybe it could be much higher but I kind
of slowed down playing master Ani yeah
and his dere points out if master rank
is kind of what matters now more and
then this DLC then and hunter rank Oh
cold I need to get my drink forgot we're
back out in the cold now
yeah yep now we're back in the game
oh that was not what I wanted but I
somehow made it out all right
you should come over to this wall
actually run me over here yeah it was
right there nice nice nice so I haven't
cut a tail off yet and I need to fix
Oh game you know game it's okay every
time okay
but one of these times I know it's just
gonna lie it's just gonna straight-up
crash same she says hi and then bye oh
oh okay well it's good to see ya thanks
for joining let's just do another one
get him to the wall very nice yeah get
back what are you doing yeah hit him hit
him hit him faster faster
oh man that is made with a more annoying
and mechanics in this game yeah you can
get earplugs and stuff you can when
Jules I don't have any Jules I don't
have any of my equipment
grab more rocks - Derek is saying is
tail can't be cut off yeah I wouldn't
remember your run away now yeah he's
running away you limp it yet now not yet
you may be right
this is also a pretty good arena to
fight in I like this one yeah I mean I
love this whole region I think it's
great really cool thing plan it was
gonna be awesome
hey head man
I think I already broke his head from
running into the wall he's saying
already broke the tail as well yeah that
tells got damage on Oh
all right there we go
turn em around run into the wall
do it again get us back yeah oh yes do
that yep
yeah [ __ ] do you bet it's so satisfying
switch axe is a good weapon get this
poison out of me this really like
piercing pods it's kind of really
satisfying having it all go through like
yeah huh do we do it yeah that was good
oh you really winded him this has got to
be him yep there it is not yet you I'm
not done with you yet
you could get him into the wall oh I
can't turn him turn around
good evening from the UK howdy howdy J
thanks for popping in unfortunately
we're kind of getting near the end of
the stream actually oh sure I didn't
realize what it was I mean we started a
little late but unfortunately something
like we have a couple things we got to
take care of so we can't we can't keep
it going a little bit longer
my poor cat
now it's probably good to just let him
go when I'm gonna capture him you know I
can't capture him cuz I don't have any
hate to bring any capture I don't have
any materials to make the stuff so I've
got it I got you gotta kill him I gotta
kill him
whoa did you jump on him
I guess hit him hit a minute hold on I
got a plan okay
I'll let him do his thing
should I sharpen your blade okay let's
grab these just cuz they're sittin here
Nomar says you could go to the camp and
refill your stuff to cap them so I don't
have like the materials to build it oh
okay cuz again you rush through
everything oh wow that's okay it just
takes time to build that back up yeah
then this room's pretty good for just
running him into a wall without having
to turn them so I can just do that
nice nice nice yep yep yep yep dang keep
going why is he not dead yet
why are you not dead that have been
really cool if that got him
right what that dive is still
it's gotta be close my there it is and
we finished two of her bounties
excellent doing it I shouldn't grab this
bone what am i doing Kat was gonna say
you gotta get him I'm gonna wait a bit
for him to hit the ground first anyway
but just gathering I want gather
everything all right our claws and thick
furs yeah it wasn't bad at all
I I really thought that this armor
wouldn't carry over into this but I
guess they they thought about that some
yeah lots are still good deep Monster
Hunters still very good I like this game
a lot big so uh well did we just want it
back to camp for a minute and take care
of stuff McCall call a stream I'm down
cool yeah man you make me wanna play
mouse down there yeah we should probably
yeah I got I got we got actually a fair
amount my back kind of log though I'm
trying to get through right now
yeah I decided to be a good time to look
at old JRPGs and I'm sick I'm playing
through Dragon Quest 11 now and I'm also
thinking about playing Final Fantasies
we were just talking about that yeah you
and me have never played Final Fantasy
seven yeah and I also want to play Final
Fantasy 8 because everyone says that
it's one that I'd like yeah because you
only Final Fantasy I've really played is
like 40 hours of 13 and like a billion
hours of ton of 14 for Final Fantasy 14
the best final fantasy game boats yeah I
my Final Fantasy knowledge is very
limited I played I played six which is
excellent I have never played any of the
ps1 games I don't really play any of the
ps2 games either so yeah it was pretty
much like I think thirteen was one I
played I never finished it and
and I yeah that was kind of it really
yeah I tried 15 couldn't get into it
really yeah I had a hard time getting
into 15 - and I'd really like it yeah I
just started 14 based on you Michael
never shutting up about it true
Derek say there's a final fantasy now
it's the best that's what tomorrow was
saying yeah what I'm saying I'm
interested to see seven because I never
finished it yeah yeah it's less like oh
I want to play the best one in more like
oh I want to play seven because that's
the one that they're remaking yeah I'll
be able to catch the stuff l'chaim
brain says he's got a go but thanks for
an awesome stream be back next week
thank you brother it's always good to
see you we'll see you next week have a
good weekend
have a wonderful weekend man it's
interesting I think this is actually
where we stopped when we streamed it on
ps4 that sounds about right and this is
also back when we were at the preview
event as far as we are allowed because
yeah so just things constantly wrapping
up in the same spot would you say the
better game is Witcher or Skyrim well I
mean they behave very very different
games the way they're actually
structured in play but I like Dragon's
Dogma more than Skyrim I I liked I like
to put your three more a lot I liked
witcher 3 that more than I liked Skyrim
personally but I very much enjoyed
scaring when it came out but between the
two I'd recommend yeah if you were if
you were to ask yes the answer is yaku's
EV but is the game I recommend actually
between the two I'd probably say Witcher
yeah if I pick if I pick one I would say
what you Skyrim you can probably pick up
really cheap now and there are ton of
really cool mods to kind of like yeah
play both if you can definitely play
both but I they're both great games but
personally yeah that's kinda where I'm
at the end of the day I'm not I'm never
as interested in like what's the better
of these two games cuz I'm like almost
ones like bad is it's more of a question
of what should you play first yeah or
like what do you prefer
yeah just like which is which was gonna
have more of that like tight writing
that uh you know like you're kind of
falling but narrative they've they've
woven for you
Skyrim is more about kind of
role-playing your own character and
discovering and kind of making your own
story and how just the [ __ ] that happens
to you yeah it's kind of the difference
in philosophy the way those games been
read but Mamaw stoner
Bayway monster honor great game uh yeah
man do we want to call right here yeah
alright why don't I just make sure I get
out and head back to this intro here hey
everybody thank you for watching sorry
for a little bit of a shorter stream
yeah
but yeah we will be back next week us
for another community Fridays do we know
what we're playing not yet and can it'll
be good I know that much it'll be good
and definitely a thing that you'll be
excited yeah if there's nothing new
we'll we'll go back up to the old
faithfuls your you know there's nothing
else going on I'd like to do Haley reach
there no Canadian gamer you just joined
she's just holding the stream I'm so
sorry but thanks for watching everybody
you can also check us out every weekday
at 11 a.m. where we do streams daily you
should go check out the wrap up video
for CES that I just put together with
the lovely Michael Haim and Matt Padgett
who is also Canadian very good the
Canadian connection the Canadian
connection we've made it so go check
that out cuz that was really fun video
we got to see some cool stuff
out in Las Vegas which boy that place is
a trip man
yeah but yeah we will see you guys next
time have a good weekend miss you
[Music]
you